[Music]
6 41 time for morning cup of joe with
metro sheriff joe lombardo good morning
sheriff it's great to see you
great to see you alex you know we want
to start with a
really horrible story two mass shootings
the past week
eight people killed in atlanta 10 in
boulder
as we know as you know las vegas has
already suffered the tragedy of a mass
shooting sheriff
can you talk a little bit about how
metro prepares for those types of events
well i i think it's an ongoing
preparedness
it was you can't you know like one
october i've said it publicly it's like
a one-off type event
and it's hard to what if every scenario
that
has a possibility out there especially
in police work so
what we do is try to train
for any possible scenario so the
response is similar depending on the
size of the
actual event but it's a constant
battle for us ever since 9 11
we've implemented some form or fashion
of training to address
mass events such as what occurred
so we we have the ability to scale up
and scale
down depending on the size of the vents
but it's an annual
uh training so in years past and police
work if some significant event occurred
and it was very rare event you know we
trained for that and then
everybody would forget about it and then
it's a cluster when it occurs again
so now in these situations it's an
annual training to ensure officers up to
speed
on what take place sheriff does a mass
shooting in another city prompt any sort
of reaction and response here from metro
yeah absolutely it's not not even just
any mass shootings
it's any terrorist type event that takes
place
even if it's in the european sector or
in the asian sector we still
have some sort of response because what
we learned from those type of crimes
are there's copycats or there's people
that
are motivated by what somebody else does
and so we
we motivate our troops we make them
aware through the intelligent sources
and then we respond to the specific
areas that we have concerns with
or some areas that we may be receiving
threats for so
an example would be when we had the
theater shootings in colorado
we did a constant omni presence
within those facilities uh for quite
some time and similar to what occurred
with the asian community here recently
um we've had an increase of omnipresence
of officers so the community feels
comfortable
uh that the police department's paying
attention
absolutely you know it's been a full
year now if you can believe it of the
pandemic
are there any new policies within metro
well as you can imagine we were learning
along the way too
um so in the original throws of the
cobid we
it was basically voluntary for the pp
and e and then
subsequently as we saw the positivity
rate increase
we made it mandatory for officers to
wear gloves and masks
and social distancing and washing of the
hands and everything
else that goes along with the pandemic
but then we had to
adjust how we communicated uh with the
public in our public outreach
and in those kind of forums uh what we
do as a police agency with that
community
you know building community trust it's
important that we meet with them on a
regular basis so it that made it very
difficult
in the in the um skype and you know
zoom and microsoft teams world and then
but internally we had to make some
significant cuts associated with it
because of the budget
uh so we had to get rid of some uh
standing units that we've had on an
apartment for quite some time such as
the horse patrol
we've had hiring freezes across the
board we got rid of all our part-time
employees
to the tune of 140 plus individuals
and you know we stopped hiring our or
we had to scale back on the academies
from six to three so we were just hired
for attrition
uh so that that was a big hindrance for
us um
it referenced the cove time period
and now as you can imagine we're going
to try to come out of this
moving forward but it's going to take a
long time for
us as a police department to recover
because i can't count a police officer
for almost 18 months
so now we we spool up our hiring
apparatus
we hire a police officer and then it's
18 months from today
if we hired him today to count him as a
police officer so that's
that's what's the big hurdle associated
with law enforcement
a lot of challenges oh and alex
just to build off that a little bit i'm
sorry to cut you off but you know then
the you know george floyd protests we
had to make some adjustments during that
time period
and then subsequently the what was
occurring out on the las vegas boulevard
specifically the strip in fremont street
uh with the violent crime yeah it's been
such a challenging year
really quickly sheriff we wanted to ask
you we've seen reports
of increased cases of coven 19 at
detention centers
is there an effort to get the code
vaccine to inmates or corrections
officers
yeah absolutely i mean that was a push
early on
it isn't because of what's what's
occurring now but there was a push early
on because of our concern being in a
confined space especially
uh the corrections officers are working
within the client space and
the ability to social distance so we had
to actually uh
shut down some modules uh um uh
decrease our inmate population by
various means to make adjustments for
that social
distancing concern um but in today's
number we're doing very well we're less
than two percent
um positive inmates and now with the
johnson and johnson
uh coming on board it's a lot easier
for us to offer a vaccine because it may
an average day
average stay in a ccdc is right around
18 days
right now so it'd be very difficult to
apply a two-stage vaccine so
um and it's also very beneficial for our
police officers they can
receive a vaccine as they come in into
the ccdc uh you know upon
uh arresting an individual they can also
see receiving the vaccine if they
haven't had it so
it's gonna be twofold um so with the
proliferation of johnson and johnson
it's gonna make it a little bit easier
in that space yeah and in general as
well
sheriff lombardo is wonderful to see you
thank you so much for joining us
you're welcome good to see you alex
thank you and if you have a question for
the sheriff you can send it to us
on our website eightnewsnow.com find out
if your question was answered every
wednesday